هل سيجري محادثات رسمية مع
mbs إذا لم يكن سعر الغاز خمسة دولارات
للغالون الذي يريده الرئيس ، وقد قال
هذا قبل أن يلتقي بالقادة في
جميع أنحاء العالم إذا كان ذلك في
مصلحة الشعب الأمريكي إذا كانت
مصلحة أمننا القومي و  هو
يعتقد أن هذه الرحلة برمتها
كل المناقشات التي سيجريها
على مدار تلك الأيام الثلاثة أه
مناسب تمامًا لمشروع القانون هذا
هل سيتحدث عن جمال خاشقجي مع
mbs والثاني آسف الرئيس بالطبع
سنتحدث عنه  مجموعة من
قضايا حقوق الإنسان أيضًا نتحدث دائمًا عن
حقوق الإنسان عندما نذهب
ونزور أه نظرائنا في جميع أنحاء العالم ، إنه
عنصر أساسي في سياسة الرئيس الخارجية
لا يمكنك أن تكون لديك
سياسة خارجية فعالة دون أن تكون متجذرة
في القيم و  من الواضح أن الرئيس
سيمثل هذه
القيم لجميع النظراء في جميع الاجتماعات ،
هل يمكنك طمأنة 911 عائلة
أه الذين لديهم مخاوف بشأن المعلومات المبكرة
أن الولايات المتحدة لم تكن موجودة  فيما يتعلق
بعلاقات خاطف 911 مع بعض
المسؤولين السعوديين ، بالطبع 15 من أصل 19
مختطفًا كانوا سعوديين ، هل يمكنك طمأنة
تلك العائلات الـ 9 التي يبلغ عددها 11 عائلة بأن الرئيس
سوف
يتعامل مع هذا الأمر بصراحة مع القيادة السعودية ،
ما يمكنني قوله لك هو أن
الرئيس لن يخجل أبدا من
تمثيل أه مصلحة
الشعب الأمريكي على صعيد الأمن القومي
أينما ذهب أه وهو
مستمر في بذل كل ما في وسعه
لدعم أه أهالي
ضحايا 9 11.
الحزن الذي ما زالوا
يتحملونه ولن يتورع عن
تمثيلهم وتمثيل همومهم